thank you
it's gonna be a deep night tonight
[ __ ] Thanksgiving is over it's
the last quarter [ __ ]
[Music]
well you big [ __ ]
welcome back [ __ ] Thanksgivings over
we're in the last quarter it's over
that's it with the [ __ ] turkey and
the stuffing and the white bread it's
nothing but bong hits chocolate chip
cookies and Santa Claus from here on in
[ __ ]
I'm here with my best buddy in the world
boom by Lisa at me should it be a deep
night tonight
we're gonna open up a little pair of
teeth and then we're gonna [ __ ] deep
tonight with the [ __ ] Khushi so
listen if you're under 18 hang up now
I don't want you seeing what's gonna
happen here tonight I don't want you
getting new ideas I want you on the
straight and narrow [ __ ] so if
we're gonna go beep let's start this
party right now I missed you
[ __ ] misses just last week a
lot is happening little was happened
and nothing really matters all that
matters is your heat it never had that
way I so much happened but not [ __ ]
happy I'm saying isn't what I'm telling
you believing me oh yeah these are fresh
out the box belly than me will get
[ __ ] up tonight and bam you think the
stars have something left behind [ __ ]
and they were [ __ ] on fire this last
time they must have made a mistake with
the recipe [ __ ] there we go smoke it
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
this [ __ ] smells like a transmission
shop it really does
[Music]
delicious nutritious
and it's good for the [ __ ] yeah dot
she needs
time to see the depth not really just
there's another one on deck [ __ ] ah
you wanna [ __ ] around when your creepy
friends so you wanna hang out with uncle
Joey there's uncle Joey time we know
we're going all in go going all in to
that much play if you haven't got an
anxiety attack you get one tonight
you better have dot 9-1-1 on speed dial
I don't know what uncle Joey gave me I
don't know what's going on
I feel like Owen Benjamin that's right
[ __ ]
I'll have you walk in that Park all
[ __ ] night long
[Music]
black is white or blue is brown colors
in my rifle are different somehow
[Music]
so keep the [ __ ] clamp young with
Sammy
it's a beautiful evening I miss you
we gave thanks for days ago for what we
have and what we don't have now it's
time to put that [ __ ] behind you and get
ready for the last quarter [ __ ] either
you're on or you're on [ __ ] how
you feelin me please got this MV empty
watch on you're looking for a new watch
that's the way to do it and cheap
affordable and you'll get them delivered
by Christmas peddling
[Music]
[Laughter]
the dumbest debt and what are you gonna
do it's over
[ __ ] that poisonous [ __ ] took
lives dreams took everything that's
lucky guys welcome what all these
Hillary people say well he he innovated
medicine listen he elevated medicine
because he used all the dead beep we
shot the [ __ ] in for experiments oh this
weed is tremendous Skywalker from
perennial I got two batches [ __ ]
drying as we speak for the [ __ ] week
ahead of us Portland Oregon Thursday
night oh [ __ ]
[Music]
softly how you feel about UV poster
you're perfect you're profitable let me
give you two stars is back up just to
make sure that's 700 milligrams coming
action
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna be a good week [ __ ]
you're gonna find a job your mother's on
the love you again your girlfriend's
gonna think you're a [ __ ] star if you
had the Jets tonight you covered cops up
[Music]
[Music]
given seven so they would the [ __ ]
one so that's what I'm talking about the
amazing job
[Music]
the Jets will come later using before
the flag football my fantasy came that
no fantasy pitch they know fantasy in
Vegas [ __ ] you're giving would
or you're getting would understand me I
don't know I got no time for fantasies
I'd like a [ __ ] answer
who are you oh [ __ ]
Lisa had it's time to leave out of death
[Music]
a guava Devine you get a little [ __ ]
Bangladesh oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
now you what good phase date for 27 28
27
you got three they've got 28 days to
[ __ ] Christmas what have you done
yeah what's the last thing you [ __ ]
look
get a bond component and so that's been
stopped before the year is over
Oh
[Music]
over here drool on myself like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I love it we say I say hello you
bad [ __ ]
before and then we're gonna show you
after
[Music]
oh [ __ ] this dabangg headed that
motherfucker's this is the one we've
been waiting for all week a little he's
blowing smoke out of his nose
well I think you see what happens when
you're afraid you got a [ __ ] train
you got a train Friday Saturday and
Sunday
I told me I creep over here at night and
do a bong get into him saying oh we
don't believe me wants to [ __ ] around
and play love story I've been telling
them for weeks I was a weekend back on
the train oh you hear these noises
this is the [ __ ] Skywalker a debt
payment on you
it's complete but absolutely
[Music]
barn it's a cherry skit for Blanc to see
you become one of Jerry's kids you ready
for another one
[ __ ] yeah I'm going deep tonight [ __ ]
on I love your plans tomorrow
listen call him up tell Alyssa will it
be a little late tonight
uncle Joey's showing up with Leedom
Delray's on his way let's talk about the
Twisted Sister documentary' and that's
it we're gonna start the week off very
late tonight
it's [ __ ] you no more Christmas I
wanna get yeah me all confused
did your panties all what you say it's
time for a [ __ ] bargain you're
absolutely correct the mundo when was
the last time that you
are you feeling up like a [ __ ] move
back look at that eyeball we do you see
his eyeball to the floor and ask the
people we don't fluff around here on the
church understanding you want to play
games no [ __ ] play games
[Music]
and leave it go and get some air in here
people [ __ ] dying
I've been telling you people for [ __ ]
years now wanna play games don't play
games assembly up uncle Joey in that
time the great games understanding what
a real deal here we're taking it for the
next level you know how just [ __ ]
being out yourself how brutally honest
keep your beauty so I'm an ugly
[ __ ] I'm fat I'm a loser
but you know what there's gotta be one
good [ __ ] finger there on the shore
but a Molly hate to see him go I want to
be your model that's never gonna happen
Thomasson myself understand I mean I'm
funny I'm [ __ ] giggles I'm [ __ ]
I kid who when I fought my smelly
understandability but with the election
Joey was burned is the day two days
three days after the film was that sir
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
we do it always pilot pilot and we just
open the door it's just me
[Music]
so you're getting is gonna sit there and
wait for [ __ ] [ __ ] come back with
your pocket it's a nice guy wait gonna
smoke a little bit all [ __ ] night that
say lay you're ready
you know a beautiful piece of chalk
listen
he was one
have a good time
[Music]
be kind others and make sure you take
care of the head
shook up in a wine as I feed my Jewish I
got Leo VI golly she's being watch a
football mercy torture he [ __ ] a full
person to the basketball hilarious she's
like again
[Music]
expresso punch we got [ __ ] stars you
want a little price I don't know what
you got to do we have worked a lot [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
yeah Joey and his Goomba of life the
fast of Jews we say
oh and there he is beep da whizzy no
sugar no cell you fools in this [ __ ]
[Music]
Commons you want to write a joke after
you watch it you were like I gotta do
some of my life well without speaking
once even if you don't like those music
I like those people like if you didn't
like the music man those guys own the
same [ __ ] every week here have a diamond
how about a wolf diamond just to get the
party started
listen man we're trying to give you
quality at the paint it him say how how
much more can you watch CBS no [ __ ]
joke how much longer can you sit there
Netflix's was crackle Adam little
expressive once
[Music]
240 milligrams Devin
right always forget em anyway I've got
the log in my dinner on My Fitness Pal
calm and it just let me [ __ ] know I
[ __ ] up so when I get home I gotta put
in the flesh of the fish chowder add
that chocolate was [ __ ] delicious you
understand me
nutritious and that's it people
it's November 27 another month
we got another year [ __ ] the rock and
get my thoughts together for next year
the plan of attack and Mo plan for 2017
my only plan is to separate seaso TV
code Joey you get the SPECIAL for free
how's that get two months for free on
seeso TV we'd call Joe who's better than
you
you know I'm giving you that cuz i play
games
that's right look at the dumb ray you've
called where Joe if he's watching sound
that live it's just 1972 you can be
doing that do you understand me you just
sit there smoke dope right and something
once a night lives
now watch Belushi and [ __ ] Eddie
Murphy where they got their stunts maybe
a too young Gil Gil oh [ __ ] I don't
blame you I didn't like black-and-white
TV when I was a kidding either these
[ __ ] fossils but you gotta learn
something somewhere along the line you
gotta go back to the original and see
what's crack-a-lackin' and with that
we're gonna have to start this podcast
you know we love you at all are what you
say either start to poop we think we
once dog just to do a triple crown of
enemies listen if you're already going
to the hospital you might as well go big
we're really gonna high school yeah
[ __ ] screaming don't take me there
don't take me there
now we'll do a stunt during the plan
kill the suspense
yo I love you [ __ ] along my
heart appreciate you two again
team Del Rey will you let this weekend
[Music]
understand December 1st through 30
listen up from there if you're from
Jersey New York City Queens will see my
man team Del Rey and support he's there
at the stand it's a great club they got
a great [ __ ] menu nice Midtown
nice place and number two I'm gonna be
in Portland Oregon Thursday Friday
Saturday understand me helium [ __ ]
bring reefer don't show up with like a
[ __ ] Bible and a ukulele cuz I'll
stab you in the neck sometimes I love
you [ __ ] with all my heart
have a great night enjoy the podcast
[Music]
youtube.com I see /c / Joey Diaz yet
that's youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
don't busy with the symptom sister
documentary how's that for you
[ __ ] please my boundaries cut
sir
I love you [ __ ] stay black I
got your back and that's it Fidel is
dead
stay black